foreign
we'll be discussing some of those honors
a bit later in the Press preview it is
our first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages and we'll be checking out
the headlines tonight with Guardian
columnist Zoe Williams who's joined by
the former conservative Peter and chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight a
very good evening to both of you we
shall chat in a moment after we've had a
look at some of those front pages
certainly the ones that have arrived
here at Sky the mirror leading with the
King's first birthday honors list and
says unlike Boris Johnson's these are
truly deserved
Boris it's a fast don't back me reach
the front to the express as it reports
the former prime minister has urged his
supporters to move on and not oppose the
deranged Commons sanction
the eye claims that High Street banks
are making billions during the cost of
living crisis by increasing mortgages
without passing on interest rates to
Savers
while the guardian also looks to an
expected surge in mortgages which they
say make the Tories a time bomb
and the Daily Mail reports that the
first host pipe ban of the year has been
slapped on those living in Kent and
Sussex and don't forget scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program and you'll be able to have a
look at the front pages of the papers
while you're watching us discussing them
and to do that Guardian columnist say
Williams and former conservative mp10
chief executive of the charity business
in the community Mary McLeod a very good
evening to both of you a humid warm
evening but good of you to uh go inside
and speak to us tonight let's start with
the eyes shall we
um it's miserable reading for the
weekend this isn't it UK mortgage ripoff
Banks pocketing billions by hiking up
mortgages but not doing the same Zoe for
savings accounts
it's absolutely right to call Banks out
on
Behavior like this because they are
it's you know it's like the shopkeeper
who always shortchanges you they're
they're raising reefs when it suits them
and not raising rates when it doesn't
suit them the problem is that it doesn't
get close to what an actual absolute
catastrophe this is for the British
consumer stroke homeowner stroke saver
stroke citizen right because even if
they did hike savings rates most people
of working age do not have significant
savings at the moment so it wouldn't
make a huge amount of difference and it
wouldn't do anything to mitigate the
cost of living crisis it wouldn't do
anything to mitigate the mortgage crisis
so even while I you know I kind of
kind of the eye calling for kind of
fairness in this in these strength and
times it's still not going to touch the
sides unless
we are you know we either get
permanently used to much higher interest
rates which will cause a housing crash
if there isn't if one isn't in train
already or
I don't know some hand of God comes in
um and redistributes the housing market
but the idea that Banks could actually
just you know rebalance everything by
putting an extra two percent on savings
is fanciful yeah Mary you know a lot
about a common economics and how
business works is it fair to say that
the banks or the big lenders are
exploiting customers
well I mean certainly on this I mean
when people come out of fixed mortgage
rates which I think this is what this is
looking at and lots of people will be
hugely worried about about this as they
finish their fixed rate mortgage term
and they go on to more variable rate and
therefore they will be aligned to what
the the base rate is
um set of course by the bank of England
um so it's I mean Banks need to respond
to this and they don't have any control
over what the base rate
um that the bank of England says
um but they do have some you know
ability to adapt while the how they set
their interest rates beyond that
um on mortgage and what they offer for
mortgages so you're at a time of cost
living and there's many businesses
including banks have been trying to help
people during cost of living crisis but
this is one where when they see this
headline I think hopefully it will give
them time to reflect and and try and do
something different because it really is
important for people
um who will just end up defaulting on
their mortgages and then it just becomes
an even worse crisis so and it's got the
thinking has to be done now before that
happens yeah so do you think do you
think there needs to be some sort of um
competition inquiry in into all of this
some MPS are asking for it
well look I mean I'm really happy
whenever there's kind of profiteering
going on I'm really happy to see it it
investigated but the truth is you know
if you look at something like energy
crisis for instance and the unbelievable
astronomical profits that energy
companies are making which even against
the backdrop of the war in Ukraine the
you know the sanctions on Russian gas
even against that backdrop their profits
are unreasonable and you can bet that
when price when wholesale prices come
down your actual bills won't come down
for some time after it now that I can
completely see the justification for
investigating but mortgages they're
pretty competitive they track the bank
of England base rate
um and they compete with each other to
track it most closely so if they could
give you a mortgage under the base rate
then they then one of them would and
then another one of them would what's
going on here is the interest rates are
being used as an attempt to keep
inflation down they're not working the
reason they're not working is is
actually manifold but
somebody at the bank of England should
take into account the fact that raising
interest rates is not being effective at
cutting inflation and stop raising
interest rates
um you're married I mean it's the same
story on the front of the Guardian with
obviously a slightly different take
Story Time bombers Millions face surgeon
in mortgage rates
um the 13th time that the interest rate
is going to go up in a row uh next week
now clearly the Tories hope that
inflation is going to start coming down
by the end of the year but according to
the guardian that's not necessarily
going to be the case and it's going to
be a real issue as a conservative for
the conservatives the voters go to the
polls
yeah absolutely and they've got a point
here I mean UK Finance who's the the
banking trade body
um as I was warned about this and the
numbers offers 2.4 million they're
saying fixed rate mortgage books are in
between now and the end of next year so
that's a lot of people affected by by
this and so therefore will come into the
the territory of general election time
and where a the government will be will
will naturally will people will look to
them say what did you do about it what
have you done to try and resolve this at
times of Crisis I mean this reminds me
of the 2008 financial prizes where where
you know
there's so many issues with individuals
the impact individuals and and
entrepreneurs as well small businesses
and and some of the behaviors then in
banking were held to accountant and and
this is where customers and zoom is is
right there I mean its customers can
vote with their feet and what we need is
some banks to be really creative
Innovative around now and say you know
actually we're going to do things
differently we believe in in supporting
customers and in hard times and let's do
things in a different way that will mean
that they will see that they are valued
as customers and because it's much
easier now to to move around Banks than
than before so yeah it's customers need
to input their you know really decide
and and do something if they can yeah
okay uh let's move on to the front of
the mail uh we're going to talk about
their new uh star columnist I wonder who
it could be it's not very clear is it
from the front of the mail
um uh but the first but the the headline
we're going to talk about before the
break uh host pipe band Zoe it's here
already it's not even officially summer
till next week
I mean it's really hard to see where the
Daily Mail is going with a story between
talking about summer talking about water
companies and talking about you know the
the kind of
outrageous perpetrated against the Great
British Gardener they seem to be trying
to celebrate and be outraged at the same
time which I guess is their happy place
you know that's something that's what
they're into it's
for whatever the mismanagement of water
companies and we've had so many sewage
stories recently and so many stories
about the their failure to invest
they're completely astronomical
shareholder dividends they're you know
the fact that whichever way you cut it
the taxpayer always pays
um
all of that being said if they've put a
hose pipe ban in place it's because
there's a trout so if I personally find
it a little bit difficult to get
exercised about
okay uh let's see if Mary is exercised
about the front of the Daily Express the
headline Boris it's a farce don't back
me this is the announcement that Boris
Johnson has told his supporters not to
oppose uh the votes on Monday he says
it's time to turn the temperature down
um what what what's his thinking here
Mary
well I mean I think the the Privileges
Committee in the House of Commons there
the vote will be on Monday in the
Commons on the report that they did and
the the recent few days you know there
was lots of words going around about a
the what would happen and and I think so
I think hopefully this might try and
calm things down I mean at the end of
the day it is a committee that's set up
um and if uh and you know if you if they
didn't like the the approach of the
committee then probably that should be
done right at the start of it
um but the former prime minister is now
just trying to distance himself from us
I think by a also announcing a new job
which which it gives it gives people
something else to think about but uh but
yes the the votes will go ahead on
Monday I think it's potentially a
one-line whip so I'm not sure how many
will actually be there to to vote but a
but I would imagine that the vote will
probably go all through to support the
Privileges committee which has been set
up for the reason of the scrutiny that
they've done so
um calling free supporters to to back
down I mean he's not doing that as a
kind gesture to Richie sunac is he
I mean I think that he that the entire
idea was silly right so when the
um privileges committee dropped their
report on Thursday morning there was
that weird surge Boris Johnson wrote
1700 words in frankly columnist ease it
wasn't a tall X Prime ministerial it
didn't even really sound like a
politician he sounded like a columnist
um and you know he made all kinds of
weird slurs against members of the
committee he referred to the fact that
Bernard Jenkins used to be a naturist he
called Harry a Harman rude names I mean
he didn't even actually now I think
about it right like a telegraph
columnist he wrote more like a kind of
um you know an Express columnist it was
very intemperate his language
um I don't know whether he then asked
his supporters to come out fighting on
social media telling other Tori MPS that
if they didn't vote down the committee
his report that they could be deselected
by their local constituency parties or
whether his hardcore of supporters are
now so extreme and sort of crack
themselves that they just were doing
that as on a kind of freelance basis and
there were if you remember only a
handful of them it was Jacob Reese
Margaret with Maddie and Doris and it
was like three other people
um it even if there had been 50 Tory MPS
saying we're backing Boris we're going
to vote against this report they still
wouldn't have had a hope of voting it
down they still would wouldn't really
have had a hope of forcing Rishi sooner
to call a general election and they
definitely wouldn't have had a hope of
getting Boris into pole position in some
other kind of guys
um so that he would be a realistic
election Prospect so I think probably
he's he's called the dogs off but I'm
not sure who called the dogs on yeah
okay that's a that's a that's a very
interesting take on it um what you've
mentioned the columns are gone let's
talk about it very quickly before the
break uh Mary
um uh it's not about partygate or honors
or quitting as an MP it's about losing
weight
yes and um and a very important thing I
must say too I've spent my whole life in
a diet but yes it's all about the 11 30
p.m reading the fridge which I must
admit I do know something about uh but
yeah this he's probably trying to stay
away from politics for at least this
column and uh and focus on something
that actually a lot of people will will
sort of sympathize on which is about
wheat except what they've done here is
talk about the the ex the the drug the
the semi-glutite drug there whether it's
sexander we go VX impact there's a range
of them he'd obviously seen two of his
colleagues shed lots of pounds and and
wondered how they'd done it and
um but I yes some some GPS are giving
prescriptions for some aren't so
obviously Boris has someone that does a
but it has been approved to be to be
used that's supposed to reduce
um your appetite but yeah I think Boris
has gone back to exercise and and
willpower so so whether that people are
trying interment into fasting the five
two protein only there's a whole range
of things out there and at the end of
the day it's probably it's probably
simple maths of reducing the the bad
stuff you you put in and then getting as
much exercise as possible but yeah these
these weight loss drugs that appetite
suppressants
um are available but they're expensive
behind um behind the chemist counter
yeah Zoe I'm sure you've got lots to say
about the the column I'm going to save
it till uh look at you nodding I'm going
to save it till uh the next hour if you
don't mind but thank you both for the
moment coming up after the break more of
our press preview including who has made
it on to the King's first birthday
honors list do stay with us
thank you
[Music]
part two of The Press preview Zoe and
Mary are still with us uh Zoe the front
page of the mirror my heroes King's
first birthday honors list the mirror
saying unlike the gongs Boris Johnson
lavished on Tory cronies and party get
AIDS today's awards are truly deserved
just having a look at the list the
oldest recipient Zoe 106 year old Joan
Willett who's raised money for the
British Heart Foundation the youngest 18
year old Junior J fruit getting the same
honor for services to vulnerable
children
I mean if this list had been designed to
embarrass Boris Johnson it couldn't have
been more apropos you know he it's in
such stark contrast to what Johnson did
you know it's not it doesn't kind of
stick within its class it doesn't
reflect people who've done King Charles
a favor although I don't know what such
a favor would look like it shows a real
kind of depth of research it shows a
real respect for civic duty of quite a
modest kind I mean you know it it sort
of reminds you of what public life used
to be like before the the conservatives
went went wild I don't know maybe Mary
will disagree with that Mary
well I just think it is it's the unsung
heroes the community Champions the
Charities that have benefited from so
many of volunteers who've done
incredible things and it is inspiring
the stories really inspiring and what is
lovely is that you have the 18 year old
and you've got the 106 year old which
just shows that you know anybody can
change the country and change their
community at any age and they can
absolutely make a difference to lives
and transform
um what's going on in society around
them so we need to talk more about these
stories frankly than than the political
honors because these are
um so important to creating strong
communities and a strong society and and
I've seen so many of them in the work
with business in the community we we get
businesses to do more work in the
community and and we've just come back
from a day in Sheffield where this week
where you know we saw so many amazing
organizations but as individuals who are
leading those organizations and helping
people supporting people and that's
always the most vulnerable are the ones
that are that are challenged or or is a
really great charity like the British
heart foundation and so we you know we
there's a there's about service and it's
about that volunteering so it's it's
really good to to have this
um and I would encourage people to
nominate if you know someone who has
done those sort of things do please
nominate
um which you can do via the cabin office
website you can do it via your local
Laurel of tenant or in London there's
Adept a lot of time for each Borough and
but literally recommend people
um for those sorts of honors who have
done amazing things because they
absolutely deserve it and it inspires
other people to to do other things too
that that will transform lives and
really help communities Thrive yeah I we
should also say of course that some MPS
have been have been honored in the
king's list long-serving Tory MPS John
Barron Bob Blackman both CBE sir Ben
Bradshaw the labor MP as well who's uh
served in Exeter for for many years
um okay we've got lots more to discuss
uh after the top of the hour but for now
Mary uh and Zoe thank you